gripping his blade tightly oh my what
did I why did I start like anyway you
just speaks up and tells the group that
he's going to join the battle to help
Gojo not pleased to hear this as he
stated that he was going to be the first
to leave kashimo Sparks up his cursed
energy and warns Yuta to not interfere
as it's him who will go and fight next
seeing his boy's cursed energy flare up
akari asks you to calm down and says
Gojo had initially asked him to tag in
when he starts to lose the battle or
gets overwhelmed but yulu rebukes her
saying that since sakuna's domain
expansion is now disabled he can help
Gojo out by handling natosha kagamis
with Riker speaking up Mucky tells
kashimoto to not forget his overall role
in the special if he's defeated then
some of the backup insurance will be
gone you know it's just like but bruh if
we go for it now and take this Gamble
and win against sakuna then the
insurance won't be needed at all
probably just eager to test this new
body swapping ability Yuji takes you to
side and encourages him to go for it I
love how like this backup plan of theirs
really hasn't even been discussed at all
we kind of skipped over that month as
I've been over in the past like we know
for a fit kashimot city is going to be
the next to enter but we have no idea
when it's actually going to be at this
point but was this even spoken about
beforehand with Gojo Yuda kind of made
it seem like they've all had this chat
only days before this battle so I'm
assuming there is an underlying plan
that our team does have not just going
into this not having any plan at all but
anyways anyways they all think that
because sakuna isn't able to give us
everything and Gojo is at his best when
he doesn't need to worry about others
the setup they're currently in has the
highest probability of winning getting
slightly bummed out with this both Yuji
and you to sulk after realizing that
they're probably just going to be a
hindrance if they enter pulling them
back to reality though kashimo tells
them that that's not exactly true at the
end of the day this is Gojo's fight and
it would just be lame as hell if they
all interfered Carrie himself suspects
that sakuna might actually have a trump
card and is preserving it for later so
if the sorcerers do act too quickly and
reveal their hand so kuna might end up
using that trap card on them skipping
away from our guys though and back
inside of Shinjuku the two Massive
shikigami Attack Gojo in a combination
attack however Godzilla the attacks with
ease and lands his own counter-attack
black flash jumping back it's shown that
a guitar wasn't even phased by the hurt
and instead sends its tail to attack
which is in fact a miniature version of
the Great Serpent proving that this base
was probably made up of even more
sugargami than originally thought
ripping off the head of the serpent tail
got your watches its maharaga quickly
pushes the other shikakami aside to
protect it as it heals pondering on this
new base and more Gojo thinks that agito
is most likely made up of nue which
firstly inherited the Great Serpent Then
They Mourn tiger and round deer still
none of that even matters in the larger
scheme of things since agito has an
adapted to Limitless like maharaga has
got your plans to destroy it in one shot
slipping away for like what the second
time now another random reveal that I
almost completely missed the first time
around but what even is this mourn tiger
surely that's the 10th Chicago from the
Teen Shadows technique that we haven't
actually seen yet the lines across
agito's chest could resemble the Tiger's
markings I initially thought it was
something to do with sakona love to know
like what you guys all think and if ever
actually get an explanation on the
shikagami in the future placing this
blade on the floor maharaga flicks it at
Gojo causing the line of rival to get
thrown up into his face locking the
rocks with his Infinity Gojo then
proceeds to dodge out of the way of the
shikigami's follow-up attack continuing
dead then launches a fat head kick that
pushes the creature back turning around
Gojo quickly activates his infinity and
brings his second shokigami in closer
having seen agito use RCT to heal its
tail before godger realizes that it'll
be Troublesome if it also heals sakona
during the battle so his plan is to
firstly deal with Earth elsewhere inside
of his dank shadowy wield saguna starts
creating a plan to not let Gojo use his
prolific Hollow purple he knows that the
last time Gojo used her the attack was
amped up to 120 percent still he was
able to take it hit on with somewhat
minimal damage since it was coming from
such a large distance however due to
everything that happened since then if
Dad does hit him with even a 100 Hollow
purple right now then it will be fatal
knowing that maharago wasn't showing him
everything sukuna speaks up and asks his
shikagami how long it's going to make
him wait he's not dumb and knows it's no
longer making me shadow so demands that
it shows him what it's got following
those orders maharaja's wheel spins and
sends forth an ability that looks
exactly like sakuna's dismantle which
slices the greatest Sorcerer of today's
arm right off not leaving his shadowy
realm sakuna Chuckles and Praises
maharaga for its Adept use of his
technique while simultaneously a bunch
of the sorcerers or scream in pure panic
charcoal personally knows that this
isn't great timing at all as Gojo's
healing is currently weakened
re-emerging from his shadows and taking
the advantage sekulu punches Gojo before
quickly following up with a wicked snap
kick that since God you're directly into
the path of agato had begun flaring up
its own cursed energy egito then
proceeds to absolutely Pummel Gojo's
head with a fat right Hawk however
just shoot a hole into the surface of
Mars Gojo looking completely manic looks
into its eyes while creating an orb of
condensed blue and tells agito that for
a while now it wasn't worthy enough to
be considered an opponent in this battle
smashing his left hand down now Gojo
effortlessly thrashes around the
pathetic curse looking at sakona and
maharaga he's a means aguto's
uselessness as he catches it completely
within his new blue maximum output and
seems a pathetic creature hurling
towards the Kona and maharaga dodging
out of the way of the blast zakuna can
only watch as the amalgamation of
shikagamis is seen hurling through
Shinjuku before it is eventually crushed
and destroyed under the pure force of
Gojo's maximum output technique 41
seconds later Gojo's purple has also
wrapped its way through the battlefield
in Shinjuku but we don't actually get to
see that purple go off like that's just
a a hidden ability that has been rumored
I wonder if we're going to get the next
41 seconds in the next chapter like
that's going to be what goes down before
the like purple fires as it says you
know like there's a scar left on the
face of Shinjuku and I'm guessing the
entirety of that District in Tokyo has
been utterly wiped from the face of the
planets well yeah this is the getting
absolutely insane now subscribe and
leave a like if you have enjoyed what
I've done with the latest Jujutsu Kaizen
chapter and want me to cover the current
stuff going on weekly I don't know if
I'll call them reviews but yeah anyway
Pro like wasn't the only one thinking
that damn gold jewels hella lucky his
domain can be thrown up with one arm or
like any technique he does can just be
used with one hand I know it's it's kind
of silly to think that he'll use another
domain expansion at this point but you
know just the idea that if he was in
like a similar situation to hakari man
could have 100 just cemented his defeat
what I'm actually mainly curious about
here is this mysterious purple that was
apparently seemed out 41 seconds later
when maharaga adapt to purple or is giga
ending this massive fight next week
because there isn't a break this one
will migami ever be able to summon like
another shikagami again if he does come
back do you guys also think that
possibly sukuna actually gets finished
at the end of these 41 seconds I highly
doubt it like narratively I still think
that Gojo is actually going to lose this
fight so you Gojo fans can always suck
on that one but continuing on Schooner
like was kind of getting nervous over
the idea of taking a 100 purple to the
dome but I'm also questioning at this
point if Dad was even able to use a 100
Hollow purple after also using a maximum
output technique maybe like my
understanding is just slightly wrong not
that it even matters at this point as
everyone's understanding these have just
been completely reinvented with this
fight but I honestly don't expect it to
end next week like if you guys all saw
Gojo's arm in the final panel it's just
beginning to slowly heal now which in my
highest means it's going to go down to
fists soon plus kashimo telling Yuta to
sit the down boy this is a
1v1 on rust is like absolutely amazing
when he tries to enter and help out Gojo
but you know either way subscribe if you
are new around here and leave a like if
you want me to cover this battle weekly
until it ends obviously this won't
affect bigger vids I'm still going to be
dropping like Fair Arc videos as well
like I'm getting slowly through one
punch man and I've got one of the
Chainsaw man videos and then also doing
berserk as well that have slowly started
working on so a bunch of stuff in the
works right now either way I'm just
loving Jiu Jitsu Kaizen right now but
until next time it's been your
professional degenerate dear Volo and
I'll see you all in a birds bye